doesn't matter like how however long how
long they've been together how long bad
stuff has been happening but if the high
is high then yo you are going to stay
believe it or not it's going to take a
lot of Detachment it's going to take a
lot of like self-discipline for you to
be like for you to kind of go this High
isn't the high we want this this high is
only High because the lows have been so
like I disagree I I disagree someone
that's been a similar situation
sometimes you never know what day of the
week is let alone high as a high and
it's all about picking away at you so by
the end of it you've got no identity
yeah that's probably just his partner
and the kid's mum and these things creep
up on you I mean I put up with it for I
think less than a year but and in my day
you call the police it was like oh it's
a domestic they've never done anything
in those days so they're probably for 10
years wow